now the reason why I leave at this point
is because all of the index laws lead
you to a local right oh yeah yeah yeah
you can't but it's just it just doesn't
tend to be what we do you just go
you take that the teeth root of both
sides
now I want you to think of these and now
he's the is the bike shift okay I want
you to help me work out the log laws and
therefore what they mean in these terms
let's look at the first one okay what's
that what's the log law or the
corresponds to that index okay
stop stop stop stop that's the law but
why does it work let's punch the numbers
in this time okay if I say something
like this okay stop what does this mean
logs are answering this question how
long when you see a log
you should think that's a time that's a
duration T equals that so what I've got
here are two different times two lengths
of time and I'm adding them together
right what is this length of time how
long does it take to double something
and get to eight times bigger and it
takes me three tokens
what's this length of time five times
right so if I add three time periods and
five time periods I ought to be a
timepiece right eight years eight
minutes whatever right so I should have
like I'm growing at a rate of eight
that's our rate of two time okay so it's
going to be rate of two after a time
periods how big will I be
and the answer is to the power 8 which
is 8 times 32 which is 256 it's mm right
this is why you magically multiply these
across it's because you're adding times
so after you added that at a time that's
where you end okay this is the same law
but let's look at these ones they're
really really quick watch what's the
world while the cross wants to three
okay
stop what question is this asking it's a
time question it's how long if I'm
growing at a rate of a whatever that is
how long will it take through for me to
be the same size that I started with
answer it doesn't take me any time
I'm already that size right yeah stop
stop stop promise there he is log more
number four what does it mean if I if
I'm growing at a rate of a how long is
it gonna take me to be eight times
bigger than when I started
answer one time period last one what's
that muscle log base Hey
one over a equals how long does it take
me I'm growing at a rate of eight let's
put a number on this log base two Omaha
if I'm growing at a rate of two I'm
doubling every time period how long will
it take me to be half this size I am now
answer you've got to go back in time
that's when I was half the size I was
you'd have to go one time here you go do
you understand what's going